alors aujourd'hui j'ai la lourde
responsabilité de partager avec vous ce
thème
il n'est pas n'est pas là alors de
l'idée si vous voulez de la jeunesse de
l'idée à la réalisation du projet c'est
m
super réponse pourquoi mon père me
disait quand je vivais encore chez lui
qu'il était étudiant
je crois qu'il a fait des études en
sciences éco voilà il était encore
étudiant quand il entendait souvent son
nom à la radio on l'appelait au lieu de
politique il y avait du boulot pour lui
dans certaines entreprises privées
je crois à la cire et dans d'autres
sociétés et il se permettait il avait le
culot de décliner je sais pas s'il ya
des étudiants ici il y en a combien qui
pendant que vous êtes étudiant vous avez
des offres et en plus que vous
permettiez de vous permettrez pardon de
décliner je sais pas si vous comprenez
ce que j'ai dit il y en a pas je pense à
ma connaissance on n'a pas tout
simplement parce que la réalité que nos
parents ont connu on ne connaît pas
cette réalité là aujourd'hui avant on
avait la possibilité pendant qu'on était
étudiant pendant qu'on était encore à
l'école d'avoir un boulot qui nous
attendait à la sortie
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui et
malheureusement dans le système
francophone on a hérité d'un corpus de
pons et si on a dépensé près et a pu
analyser définit la réussite donc la
réussite c'est un cheminement
c'est un ensemble d'étapes dans l'esprit
de tout le monde ici il faut aller à
l'école ensuite il faut avoir ce type
l'eau après il faut trouver un stage
et puis il faut avoir son premier boulot
il faut fait arrière donc pour gravi les
échelons dans des entreprises
et puis après quelques années
on pourra dire qu'on a réussi donc quand
on a une grosse voiture rossemaison
voilà on a réussi donc les gens l'oeil
extérieur pourra justement les yeux des
autres jusque mon pauvre on nous fait
croire vous fait comprendre qu'on est
dans une position de réussite est comme
gelée dit d'entrée les réalités neutre
non plus les mêmes
et comme on est formaté de cette façon
si à un moment donné dans le pot c'est
ce que j'ai décrit tout à l'heure on a
un problème s'est dit qu'on n'a pas pu
terminer les études où on a terminé des
études on n'a pas pu trouver un stage où
on a trouvé un stage on n'a pas pu
trouver un boulot quand on ce cheminot
là on rencontre un problème vu qu'on a
été formaté de cette façon on est un peu
perdu
on ne sait plus quoi faire résultat des
courses taux de chômage super élevé
beaucoup de gérants de cabine à tous les
carrefours taux de cybercriminalité donc
on appelle route neuve super développer
super élevée pardon ici en côte d'ivoire
et même en afrique et du coup on se pose
la question est de plus en plus
aujourd'hui ce genre de conférence là
nous ont permis de comprendre online on
est une voie en une sortie on a une
solution et on a tout à l'heure avant
que la conférence ne commence j'ai vu un
speaker qui parlait d'entrepreneuriat on
nous dit que c'est la porte de sortie
donc le système anglo saxon il est
différent de celui que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure on peut le match cup étudiants
et créer facebook être dans le top 5 des
plus grandes multinationales aux montres
on peut être larry page ou je ne sais
pas qui d'autre ne pas fini ses études
et et être milliardaire en fait est en
fait la voie de sortie
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
notre peau et narnia men
l'entrepreneuriat en fait c'est le fait
de créer bien entendu une société à
partir d'une idée
donc du coup on touche tout de suite on
pointe du doigt le thème qu'on a cet
après midi c'est l'idée
comme on part d'une idée à la
réalisation des projets mais avant
comment nous viennent les idées
je pense que c'est un peu la question
fondamentale on se pose souvent on a
envie on nous a dit qu'il faut être
content mais au moins j entreprends
hautmont méfier l'idée c'est quoi l'idée
qui va au quai ses qualités je pourrais
avoir qui va me permettre d'entreprendre
est justement de donner du boulot et de
payer mes impôts
donc je sais qu'il ya plusieurs écoles
moi j'ai retenu quatre ou cinq points
que je partage avec vous rapidement sur
le process ou comment on pourrait avoir
des idées donc le premier point il faut
déjà élargi son champ de connaissances
premier point je dis qu'il faut
on a la chance d'être allé à l'école il
faut pas se contenter du cursus qu'on a
fait curieux folie des livres il ya deux
ou trois semaines j'ai contré
d'apprendre à développer sur supputons
je suis pas informaticien
je suis marketers j'ai fait un peu des
finances et j'ai créé un autre supputons
j'ai vu sur facebook pacifique sud
google fait des richesses
j'ai vu des documents j'ai lu et j'ai
essayé de créer des coudes
donc il faut et polly et moi je lis je
lis tous voila je nie des magazines
spécialisés des magazines religieux
enfin je lis donc je pense qu'il faut
élargi son champ 2 de réfection il ya
quelqu'un qui disait on créait à partie
de ce qu'on connaît
donc si tu ne prenait pas tu ne peux pas
crier voilà donc il faut il faut il faut
élargi premier point son champ de
connaissances deuxième point est un
passe temps que j'aime bien qui
s'appelle mohamed sanogo qui dit pour le
devient que ce à quoi on pense que plus
voilà c'est dit tu deviens ce à quoi tu
médites peu plus ses deals c'est qu'ils
dominent dépenses et des réflexions
cessé en fait ces serres c'est ce qui te
fare sonne et c'est ce qui c'est ce que
tu deviens on dirait le fruit de nos
réflexions de nos pensées
convenez avec moi que dans une journée
on a
une pensée qui nous traverse l'esprit
donc là je suis pas en train de parler
des idées ou des pensées qui nous
traversent je parle des idées ou des
pensées tu lesquels on s'arrête sur
laquelle on prend du temps méditer voilà
est le deuxième point justement c'est
pas un suspect - la cm
le rêve voilà il faut arrêter d'être
focus qui ne marche pas malheureusement
en côte d'ivoire et les jeunes ivoiriens
quand on regarde un peu sur les réseaux
sociaux les gens contents ça aa rester
focus qui n'est pas bien récemment on a
une attaque terroriste
les gens se sont mis à attaquer le
gouvernement les policiers les
militaires et les gendarmes la rti tout
le monde
voilà une info qui sut les problèmes on
et focus eu des problèmes on est
justement pour soi même on regarde ce
qui ne marche pas j'ai pas d'argent
tout à l'heure on adhère le speaker
précédent à donner justement des idées
on a reçu et des personnes qui ont fait
fi de ces idées là pour réussit donc
l'âge la condition financière
voilà donc il faut il faut arrêter de
focaliser son esprit su ce genre de
choses et puis rêvée pour rêver moi je
sais pas je pense que ça ne coûte rien
de rêver n'est-ce pas ça ne coûte rien
de rêver
moi j'ai eu la chance d'être un gros
réveil j'ai rêvé je rêve depuis je suis
au lycée je rêve un club les yeux quand
j'imagine quand je me projette on l'a vu
ni c'était un avenir radieux et glorieux
que je performe atteindre mon esprit je
me disais que j'allais réussi j'allais
dans une grande maison
j'avais construit une grande entreprise
à l'embauché des milliers de personnes
et je nourrissais ce rêve là et chaque
fois quand j'ai même des difficultés à
l'école quand j'ai eu une mauvaise
l'autre en europe pour me consoler j'ai
fait ce film là avant de donner mon avis
ça sera si ça sera ça mais je vous dis
la vérité
naturellement les choses se sont
disposés devant moi ma faveur c'est
métaphysique j'ai fait un effort n'était
pas brillant à l'école disons premier de
classe depuis la maternelle g star
puisque en terminale non pas du tout
mais chaque fois où il fallait être
brillant pour passer à une étape
supérieure important d'électeurs
voilà j'ai jamais été primés des classes
sauf en terminale voilà est en terminale
j'ai été imprégné et ça m'a permis de
rentrer à l'ump par exemple et après
quand je suis sorti de l'école
je n'ai pas jamais déposé de cv mon
premier boulot
ben on m'a appelé bien travailler et
quand je quittais que je parte ailleurs
pareil et c'est comme ça que les choses
se dispose naturellement devant moi
comment j'ai créé ma société je n'ai pas
fait dépister ce plan je n'ai pas
cherché des financements je n'ai pas
pleuré j'ai pas dit qu'une banque n'est
pas j'étais assis là et on m'a dit qu'on
vient ont créé une société
voilà les chaussures voilà c'est magique
pourquoi parce que je rêve donc 2 le
deuxième point justement me semble qu'il
ne reste pas beaucoup de temps
il faut rêver il faut arrêter troisième
point de regarder ce qui ne marche pas
regarder autour de vous les gens ont des
problèmes
essayez d'imaginer regarder les
problèmes des gens et puis imaginer des
solutions qu'on pourrait apporter aux
problèmes des gens voilà ça peut vous
donner des idées de création de piste un
point on dit qu'on afrique on est
dernier ben c'est un bon point
ça veut dire que les autres ailleurs on
fait quelque chose on peut copier
intelligemment
quand je revenais de eur dont j'ai fait
un stage linguistique en angleterre je
suis revenu avec une idée de projet j'ai
beaucoup joué à l'aide des derniers pour
faut pas avoir peur de l'échec
je suis revenu avec des idées de projets
le premier projet vu un magazine la base
d'un gratuit ça n'existait pas ici il
s'appelle le friday a hâte c'était ma
classe et magazine qui paraît tous les
vendredis c'est le rendez vous ont fait
tu as des petites infos les petites
annonces là dedans et tu as envie
d'acheter un animal soit 8,9 et un peu
d'argent qui cherchent du boulot tout ce
que tu veux tu l'as dans ce magazine là
il était gratuit et ce magazine tourné
bien univers de la publicité je me suis
dit mais pourquoi ne reproduirait pas un
modèle ici pourquoi je suis venu j'en ai
parlé à deux ou trois personnes qui
m'ont découragé et quelques instants
après il ya eu des magazines gratuits
qui voilà qui ont commencé j'ai
je me suis dit aussi mais je peux pas
être content c'est vrai j'ai pas mal
d'idées mais je peux pas je viens de
gagner 500 me font tous les mois pour
assurer mes charges et où si je dois
aller 6 ans est-ce que je suis sûr que
tout de suite je peux donc nous régler
ce souci là j'étais amie et moi on a
créé une société qui s'appelait 18h30
on travaille pour les gens jusqu'à 18
heures et à 18 d'être important est que
nous venons à 18 à 30 ans se voyait tous
les soirs et on travaillait sur nos
projets on avait pas mal d'idées on
tentait de développer ça n'a jamais
abouti
donc j'ai joué aussi la voilà mais je me
suis pas arrêté j'ai eu l'idée de succès
assuré
il ya cinq ans au départ je ne savais
pas comment gagner de l'argent avec une
fille dit ben nous quand on était élève
on a eu besoin d'avoir des anciens
sujets d'examen donc ça pourrait
intéresser les élèves d'avoir une
plateforme numérique des anciens sujets
d'examen peut-être avec des corrections
et j'ai réuni des amis aussi assis on a
développé je suis pas développeur on a
développé on a on a acheté des anciens
sujets leur fait les annales là on a
numérisé on a mis en ligne pendant deux
nuits dans un garage que pas s'il a su
lever jeu abidjan et on a fait la
promotion sur les réseaux sociaux on a
eu beaucoup de bénédictions n'a jamais
eu d'argent mais les gens nous ont
beaucoup vu son pays et au bout de cinq
ans on a signé un contrat important avec
mtn on a signé un autre contrat avec
orange mais en france le groupe et il
s'apprête à envahir déployer ce système
là sur tous les pays où il ya orange en
afrique avec un chiffre d'affaires
prévisionnel par pays
donc par filiale de 80 millions mois
pour multiplier par le nombre de
filiales quelque chose qu'on a au départ
on enfile pour s'amuser c'est devenu un
projet super important et voilà
dernier point il faut pas avoir peur il
faut par peur de l'échec
l'échec c'est un apprentissage
considérer cela si vous avez échoué
qu'on n'avait rien perdu moment vous
aurez essayé
voilà et vous en tirer des leçons pour
le nextep donc le second gros points
j'ai abordé le premier post a comment
nous viennent les idées
j'avais fait en deux minutes rassurez
vous c'est comment alors le transformer
en projets viables
alors il faut rester focus eu son rêve
il ya d'autres plateformes vont je vais
à l'école mais mon ancienne il faut
faire un business plan il faut ça c'est
pas le lieu
mais moi je veux juste vous dire que le
rêve que vous aviez quand vous créiez ou
non vous aviez cette idée il vous a
poussé à commencer la création faut le
garder parce que quand vous aurez des
difficultés parce que normalement vous
en doré sûr c'est ce rêve là qui va
faire que vous allez demeurer fermes je
vous demande chers amis de fouiller dans
vos esprits mais chercher l'idée qui
justement permettra d'aller aux martys
book aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est avec
le numérique
ça va très vite donc je souhaite avoir
le prochain facebook
il sort de cette salle je vous remercie